you have to believe that anything is
possible today's world it's almost like
they don't want us to accomplish our
dreams you know they fill our days with
distractions and a disbelief in that you
have to be a certain way to be
successful and that's just not true you
know human design is all about
deconditioning yourself back to your
authentic being
so that you can really your energetic
Aura can be inviting the universe to
send you what you right are really meant
to have and you can be fully expressed
in what you're naturally inclined to do
right yeah you don't have to wake up at
5am if that's not what you're meant to
do to be successful you can still be
successful without
being exhausted